hello and welcome to the honest trailer
comte for deep blue sea the show where
you'll get a peek behind the curtain at
our unvarnished unfiltered oh yeah
censored thoughts about the film and if
you stick around to the end you get to
see some deleted scenes that's nice oh
right yeah I'm Spencer J Gilbert dan
your hats not like a shark's fin but
here you are anyways Here I am neither
was that one cool cool Jeff and Joestar
I am neither deepest or bluest yeah I
gotta say smooth is kind of fun it's
really profoundly stupid but it knows it
I think in a way that toes the line
between like sharknado and from what I
hear about the Meg it's just self-aware
enough and silly enough that and dated
enough let's be real at this point yeah
it was an entertaining rewatch for me
dated for sure I always thought this
movie going back to when I first saw it
other than the same Jackson moment which
was the movie being aware of what it was
I always thought it actually took us a
little too seriously I know a lot of
people loved it for being this like
campy good bad movie I think it's really
just not a very good movie it never
really seemed to embrace that fun for me
it was always very kind of serious
except for that one again the one moment
where they realized hey let's have fun
with this and see what the audience I
love that moment so much it's such a
great moment and it played like
gangbusters in the theatre yeah I mean
it was great because they are setting up
that Avalanche story in the whole film
yeah it's like he's finally gonna tell
us what happened in the Avalanche so
you're already on the edge of your seat
waiting to see what comes out of his
mouth and that's when he gets eaten by a
street shark a street shark yeah Joe
feelings yeah you know I think I think
they do a good job of making this a good
bad shark movie you know we've got dumb
lines you know you wake my bird and
throws the lighter on a shark I mean
that that's really good it's pretty
stupid the the CG just getting worse and
worse as time goes on kind of makes this
like sweet in a way we're like oh look
what you tried to do
electronic shark was really good yeah
animatronics are good they should have
used that more no that can't like
awesomely rip someone into I think they
recycled some animation oh they
definitely a couple of those deaths are
completely yeah the doctor doctor
science ladies death at the end is was
like a really last-minute rush job
because they had to change the ending
yes that stream that one just looks
amazingly terrible because they in the
initial version of the movie they get to
the end and dr. science lady who is
created these sharks she's responsible
for all of the bloodshed that's happened
it's her drive to do it they thought she
was the hero of the movie yeah and she
lived in the first version it was like
okay she's horrible but then it got in
wrestling terminology a huge pop I
believe I'm using that correctly here
when they recut it so that she was eaten
horrifically yes by a shark yes and you
can tell they wedged in there because it
feels completely and also she poured in
it doesn't make sense I think they were
like what did being the bait accomplish
because it doesn't really accomplish
nothing that it doesn't matter they're
just like whatever he's got to go it's
like it's swimming toward Thomas change
like I'm gonna jump in and she jumps in
and it gets her and then it still gets
goes I don't know I guess it whatever
doesn't matter
yeah why are we analyzing sharks I used
my one of my this came out 1999 yeah I
think I've talked about this before I
had a limited number of right in our
movies I could see every year hmm I used
one of my rated R movies on this movie
this is one of the I think five because
even back then my favorite movie was
jaws yeah any shark movie I wasn't sure
then this is one of the five rated R
movies that I elected to see that year
and at the time I was not disappointed
not this is good 1999 popcorn Fair
that's Sam Jackson moment was a great to
see ya and you know what I think it
speaks to deep blue sea that as a film
from 1999 this is one we still like
talked about a lot you know just it's
the matrix it's Fight Club those came
out in 99 because that's a it's a big
movie year I'm gonna be which being John
Malkovich
six cents yeah we still talk about the
stupid shark movie like a lot yeah
because that's how gloriously dumb it is
it's pretty stupid yeah and they're all
well LL Cool J a huge TV actor these
days Sam Jackson also still in
everything stolen everything Thomas Jane
that's Thomas Jane doing so right he's
knocking around dr. science dr. science
late Mozart in the jungle yeah he was
indeed yes it's just fun it's a look
back at a really weird collector tell oh
and Avengers dr. science man dr. science
man yeah Michael Rapaport I feel like
saying that he'll now bust through the
back yeah it's like my kool-aid man by
nightmares I don't listen do the Howard
Stern Show as much as I used to but they
were in they had a fantasy football
league on the show and he was in it yeah
and it sounded like the most miserable
experience that any of them had ever had
they're like why did we let this guy
because he was relentless personal he
would go after them their kids their
families their wives he was just like
relentless yeah not my kind of seems
like a bad hang anyway it sound like
you'd call you a chunder head yeah I was
trying to think of like what's a New
York insult and I'm my mind pigeon dog
he'd be the one New Yorker who when
Spiderman was in trouble like wouldn't
bother helping save spider-man let's
watch deep blue sea
some requested not made him scary the
mag made him big and NATO made him blow
but in 1999 the same shark movie again
every 5 years came with a twist
the Sharks are smart and this movie is
dumb Lucy can we adjust that real
quickly the idea and it's true every 5
years or so we get there was shark night
and shark Night 3d operator open water
the reef the shallows that's what yeah
but every five years there's like one
medley I'm supposed to be like the the
cheesy fun one that was I think that was
this one it was shark night the mag the
mag is now and they say every five years
there's one that's like no this one's
this one's this one's supposed to be bad
yeah a sharknado now there's one every
two weeks yeah go shark yeah shark plus
natural disaster whatever yeah so if you
haven't seen ghost shark watch ghost
shark at one it's about a shark that's a
ghost oh and that's easy to animate and
at one point someone's like filling like
a slip and slide with like a garden hose
yeah and go shark comes out of the
garden hose meets them oh cool
yeah I definitely came through Avalanche
sharks good that one was good they swim
through the snow Mega Shark versus giant
octopus yes a good very good slash
terrible I've decided that one has Dean
Cain in it does it have Dean Cain not
that I know of I I don't think it has
anyone okay that you've ever heard of it
it's that far down the chain okay asylum
if you're listening is it gonna get us
let us be eaten by sharks
well we'll be talking about it right
here we're available suit up for the
ultimate b-movie
a good fella this is a bad fella okay
second all twenty booby and remove the C
to a lab bill for one purpose to trap
its employees underwater the elevator
feels off automatically to keep the
shaft in facility and also to cure
Alzheimer's by sucking at the brains of
unconscious super sharks as a side
effect the shots got smarter okay sure
whatever in this poor man's report or
genetic pollination complete with
approaching tropical storm running on a
skeleton crew on their most important
weekend
Sam Jackson hiding in a kitchen C button
it's like the same it's like he just
goes into like alright and we're gonna
push in on each dude a three-quarter
shot it's just like he's like okay which
glass yeah what glass is in my way
because it's the same I'd like to point
out the six years apart and they looks
like they could have filmed it
back-to-back yeah the same facial
expression it's the same can you go full
screen his hairline filled in it did fit
ice airline filled in yeah it's like he
just has that he has the Sam Jackson
look he's got that ineffable Sam Jackson
look about him we just watched hit man's
body guard cuz it came on each bag is
not aged yeah yeah no it's pretty crazy
here he'll do anything for a million
dollars that's just I mean would mean
but but like as far as any role and any
like appearance commercial whatever he's
just kind of not a flat-rate but like
give me a million dollars they'll do
your stupid thing noted that's why you
see a lot of Sam Jackson it's not
shocking good for him
this also being a completely unsourced
rumor that I heard someone say so
proceed Sam yet hiding in a kitchen
scene and guy who gets eaten for
resetting the power but instead at the
iconic John Williams score
LL Cool J gets to rap about how his hat
is like a shark's fin
isn't though he Ana morphed which is
incredible pan shark head shark this is
when movies when music videos made for
movies were amazing like they would
always do it would be intercut with
footage from the film yep sometimes
before the movie came out yeah and these
big CG budgets may had plot lines of
their own Will Smith dancing with the
aliens usually was dancing yeah yeah
movie tie-ins particularly were like
little little mini movies unto
themselves you get so you get to see
some exclusive clips yeah
godzilla throwing a helicopter at P
Diddy's penthouse for come with me yes
and then this is also a phenomenon that
you see a lot in the mid to late 90s is
movies that are almost just there to
sell their soundtrack because there's
multiple scenes this movie with like
someone whips out a boombox and starts
plans in mid nineties R&B like someone
else's puts out of boombox and starts
playing mid 90s R&B it's very clearly
like the soundtrack is a way to get
twenty more bucks out of people most
comedy films produced in the years 1995
- I'll say 2002 were more or less to
sell soundtrack albums we used to pay
for music it was crazy we did that's
yeah discs I would also like to point
out that the worst slash best tattoo
I've ever seen was a girl who had
deepest bluest and then a shark's fin as
a hat and said my head is like a shark's
fin like visible like right here I just
I was beside myself I didn't quite know
how to hit yeah that's a lot I'm sure
she's still got it
out there that's how tattoos work yeah
good for her commit to in a bit anyway
just keep going
it isn't though go down under with the
shadiest group of shark snacks and boys
night on the Orca
they are serious badass for the past I
don't make waves I mean the terms of my
parole
the former preacher with a past I have
looked the Pope and I love the bottle
the head scientist with the past
everyone needs someone like the
assistant trans over five made it out
but in his case that past never involved
asking what he spent billions and
billions of dollars on suppose it's in
the name it's in the name i Rangel
Charlotte I'll give you one guess okay
your you'll need half of a guess but
I'll let you guess what a shark Wrangler
does yeah the whole fukaku setup of like
I've run this company yesterday and I
just say yeah that is repeated beat for
beat in the Meg oh really
the see Wayne Wilson shows up he's like
so what do all my money buy me it's like
you what else were you doing that's what
you doing that you don't know what you
should buy it more with like someone
more to like their brain Wilson age like
some like just rich Silicon Valley
Jackson took an active role in
leadership in his company this is a guy
that's a CEO of a pharmaceutical company
maybe I don't have any beginning yeah
he's a CEO of he's also there with the
guy from Robocop was just like also in
the room but yeah oh yeah at the
beginning yeah unlike the yes it was
yeah that guy from Robocop he's like the
go-to eighties business dick yes and
he's in that Hulk Hogan movie too he's
the bad guy yeah yep not over the top
but I verify if I notice you some
Robocop was like oh it's that business
guy yeah anyways he must have spent
several billions of dollars to build a
science lab at the bottom of the ocean
for one
we're mental drugs it was the only thing
they are doing is growing shark brains
five times larger than normal to then
basically knock them out unconscious and
then and then suck out that drug there
was no a lot of I'm kind of like and how
are you how are you gonna scale that I'm
gonna in smarten every shark on the face
of the earth to draw one vial of uh
I think step two is maybe you
miniaturize them so they're really cute
make their brains huge but then their
bodies are they pills do you eat them
like little family members who like work
on cancer drugs and I feel like they
have to share a cubicle with someone
like this whole billions of dollars for
the undersea lab for one disease thing
it doesn't the hope of finding hope
while I'm cure for one disease yeah and
then which goes back to we didn't pause
it but you pointed this out I was like
god you're right
what is with these places working on
skelet working with skeleton crews on
the most important weekend and maker
breaks during the make or break test
it's gonna determine whether this lab
stays open or not send everyone home
yeah like that's the weekend boat
everyone's leaving
I guess it's cheaper but on the other
hand just have more people for the shark
day but you want to press the guy and
you want to make it seem like yeah
you're you don't first of all all of
those people would be fired it works is
like well you five can run again clearly
you've none of you have a problem doing
the most important work you'll ever do
with just you five so all of the rest of
them are buying shark shark Wranglers
two through six or gone yeah yeah and
including the woman who what's she from
she's a frantic person whose job is just
there to like tell them what the weather
is like they can just look at the
weather there's like it's coming water
rain up here keep going Wow just what
the hell did you do
somebody please tell me what that is
well that's a fair question actually it
stellan skarsgård attached to a gurney
about to turn your lab window skarsgård
shock chards well trust him that five
times fast
scores go short-shorts course car shock
charge her score coast guards I forget
it
should we try skarsgård shark shark
scarred scarred shark shark skarsgård
shark shark scar scar got the four
skarsgård shark shark one and a half
skarsgård sharks charged skarsgård shark
shark starts good yes all right
you try it at home try it in the
comments below all right keep got up in
for the only Christian shark movie you
need to see or even knew existed where
God's vengeful creatures attack
teenagers for premarital sex and
drinking punish evil scientist's for
defying the natural order and one of the
only two to make it out alive is named
preacher nice
maybe I'm just reading into things but
help me out here wouldn't you rather
watch deep blue sea know something
father Abraham a thousand times Joe and
I had to put our heads together to
remember we actually go to Sunday school
he did school because macaroni art which
seemed kind of highfalutin Sunday school
you went to her own E budget nope father
Abraham had many sons I just remembered
learning father Abraham for many
multiple years in a row at Sunday school
yeah I don't know finally that
information came in handy yeah finally
no that was a good song for the 180 d
kid in Sunday school aka me who like
needed to get like all of this like it's
like a call-and-response song ya know
cut your arms and legs and you have to
name all the sons no no Isaac Daniel no
I don't know no but I was one of them
and so are you
right it didn't make simply why drink
out into like the that shirt stop making
sense there's no way to have a dance
with it I think it was literally just to
get kids to move and tire them out
because other than smart that there was
ya know it's really crazy more you know
Sunday school that Sunday school for you
keep going ready just stare ominously
out of porthole Stillwater
react to tremors like the original cast
of Star Trek
funny magic manifests economics giving
him lemon and get absolutely drenched
over and over and over again in wet set
and since I came with a sabores though
they had to be painful yeah
for a fill with just one main one when
the when they're in the main lab and the
water breaks through that was supposed
to be a rehearsal with no water like
someone screwed up
oops and so that but that was the take
that they kept was everyone freaking
cool that's all yeah good shot for a
fill with just enough sharks lock to
prove that the only thing harder than
making a good shot tongue twisters is
making a good bad shark movie never
thought I'd say this but
sharknado kinda had the right idea
[Applause]
see I want that part in the sharknado
movie yeah like they're candy yeah right
surely it should be that hard right yeah
like a wasn't no way like would that get
me into sag mmm maybe please put us in a
shark weather movie yes pick a disaster
pick an animal if doesn't even have to
be sharks know we're there yeah it could
be flood guerrillas no octa Kane look at
you can actually combining the words
together squid Nami
wake asaurus rex perfect yeah
it's an earthquake that's also a
dinosaur lizard no storks yes no storks
sounds like an off-brand Pixar movie
starring the punished shark I've had it
with these monkey fighting sharks in
this Monday to Friday I've had it with
these monkey fighting snakes on this
monday to friday plane which is well the
old time that's an epic a mr. Falcon and
the French a stranger in the else you've
got
I've seen this Monday to Friday lab
sitting on the dock with Cool J Michael
Rapaport as himself
trust me she's smart see sharks on the
seafloor ocean water I guess is what
they were going for and all these homage
is to Jaws stuck in my craw
the whole John's franchise they all
Amaro these are all that's one that's
once a license plate
that's why
this is - its jaws - is the end of just
three
and this is John sport the shark tank
redemption cuz their shark president I'm
usually against English sequels but if
this is a prequel to a street sharks
movie I am so on board and so it's been
diesel yes we finally got to use it
neither of you know the background of
that it was a toy oh I don't know it was
like when they hire people to like like
exhibitors come and they look at the
coming product lines and Vin Diesel was
hired to be like the pitchman yeah the
video is amazing he's really good it was
like this is hammerhead he loves to
punch people with his vicious uppercut
[Laughter]
yeah yeah good friend it's actually
quite good at that job yeah I have to
say I wish you would do it again I
always fall back yeah if the whole movie
star thing doesn't work yeah exactly you
can definitely go back to UM to Hawking
toys nice yeah all right
what didn't we put in the video you
watch storage Todd shocker homeless dad
I represent Queens she was raised in a
shore crab Hell's Kitchen dr. Bell's
cueing dory bow shark in the jungle dr.
English MD stellan skarsgård making
shark shards a bridge over troubled
water Shaquille O'Neal
all of the surgeries are starring shark
shark week and jabber jaws Sealab 1999
shark tail you ate my bird
I think it's safe to say that Steven
Seagal is the second most badass cook in
movies just our special envoy for
us-russia relations yeah so and a deputy
sheriff and acknowledged and a lawmen
have you seen the series based on his
deep state novel have you read his deep
state novel no and no and where can I
find a copy of said being state novel
I'm gonna buy us an office copy I think
okay great yeah well I guess we'll be
back with a book report yes next week oh
now trailer commentaries because we've
said all there is yeah next week's
honest trailer it's kind of a book
report and that it's based on a movie
based on a kind of a book now that's bad
that's a bad metaphor but it's next week
oh it's a big one
hang on yeah what is it yeah I forgot no
it is it's pretty big yeah yeah yeah
well you'll just find out how big could
it be infinitely big I don't know yeah
we'll see we'll see oh I get it right
Joe we'll see you next week come back
honest trailer commentaries public
you